nos encontramos en una de las posiciones
A las afueras de backmud que todavía
está en control de las fuerzas
ucranianas lo que ha hecho haz las
fuerzas rusas después de esta gran lucha
que comenzó en verano ha sido en Isla
encerrando por de diferentes flancos
solamente queda un flanco en el oeste y
Son varias poblaciones que todavía están
en control de las fuerzas ucranianas que
ellos luchan con todas sus fuerzas para
mantenerlas abiertas y de aquí seguir
lanzando una contraofensiva para
expulsarlos y hacerlos retroceder los
ucranianos todavía tienen el control de
la zona central de bakmuth a pesar de
que los rusos por donde van van
Arrasando edificaciones también
destruyendo esos subterráneos esos
sótanos desde donde también operan las
fuerzas ucranianas pero ahí siguen dando
la batalla sin embargo el acceso cada
vez es más complicado la lucha se ha
intensificado desde el de semana según
nos cuentan los soldados que están aquí
sin embargo hemos estado con una
posición que maneja algunos de los
drones y nos dicen que hoy después de
dos días de grandes enfrentamientos ven
menos presencia de las fuerzas rusas en
la región sin embargo se escucha
bastante fuego bastante artillería de
entrada y de salida lo que significa que
la batalla continúa los ucranianos según
han dicho desde el Ministerio de defensa
han traído más refuerzos después de que
el general de esta zona estuvo aquí el
pasado sábado sin embargo también ellos
cuentan que los rusos van reabasteciendo
y reabasteciendo el número de hombres en
la medida que avanza la batalla Así que
este es el centro Aquí están los ojos de
toda Ucrania por una batalla que es
estratégica tal vez más que militar sino
moral para los rusos que han invertido
muchísimo capital humano y militar por
la captura de este lugar y también para
los ucranianos que también han resistido
con muchísimo esfuerzo y con también la
vida de miles de hombres en este lugar y
que es estratégica porque de llegar a
perderla permitiría que muchísimos
soldados rusos queden libres y puedan ir
a pelear y avanzar en ofensivas en otras
regiones del país especialmente en el
don Baz que es el gran objetivo en este
momento del presidente Vladimir